hey everyone my name is Jessie and today
I'm gonna be testing out which egg
scrambles the best I have eggs from
quails chickens ducks and a day has even
blessed me with a mother in an ostrich
egg I'm gonna scramble them all try to
keep it completely the same and fair and
I'm gonna feed it to three egg lovers in
the office let's get to the bottom of
this and let's see which egg
scrambles the best first I got these
cute little quail eggs
I'm snipping them open with these
special scissors that takes the top off
without crushing them I had to open 18
of them just to make enough to make one
batch of a scrambled egg I'm gonna
season them up with salt some pepper and
I'm gonna cook all these eggs in some
butter over medium heat no fancy at this
time so don't at me in the comments bags
look a little more yellow than a typical
chicken egg so I'm interested to see if
they taste any different than chicken
egg gonna server on top a toast season
it up with a little bit more salt and
pepper and that's it it's got some good
coloration I see some white some yellow
some pepper looks like scrambled eggs
maybe a little darker there's not as
much like white yoki part
oh that is creamy this is so soft oh my
god
I would totally put this in a bacon egg
and cheese sandwich feels like as if you
wouldn't need the cheese if this was
just what's blows in the sandwich it's
like if a stick of butter and an egg
just had an orgy this is really good up
next we have good old chicken eggs and
chances are we all know what scrambled
chicken eggs look and taste like so
instead I'll take this time to tell you
some chicken egg backs first a GNote
chicken eggs can come in green blue pink
brown or white depending on the chicken
and did you know that the average person
in the u.s. consumes over 275 eggs
that's a ton of eggs so back to these
eggs
they look pretty typical so I'll put
them on toast I'll season them up with
some more salt and pepper and that's it
but this one is much more yellow all the
way around so give it a try oh it's
gooey on the inside this one's good too
it doesn't taste like a normal egg it's
bolder it's confusing me it's like when
you see somebody once where you don't
really know what it is about them that
has fiery like damn that person's got
swearing these are these scrambled eggs
I got swagger I just don't know exactly
what it is
it's the perfect egg up next we have
duck eggs which are a bit larger than
chicken eggs and the shells are a bit
thicker and they kind of feel paper and
if you notice the yolks are larger than
chickens but the whites look super
watery they almost have no color and it
kind of feels mucousy when I whisk them
together so I'm going to cook this just
like the other ones just some butter
some pepper nothing fancy
and I noticed that they're really really
pale in color so I wonder if that means
they're gonna be less flavorful so I'm
gonna serve it up on some toast season
with salt and pepper and there you have
it scrambled eggs
it looks like very desaturated like
there's barely any color to it
oh wow it's really smooth you know the
yolk flavor how it kind of tastes like
this
chalky kind of like flavor it's like
that definitely don't judge a book by
it's cover because this unsaturated egg
it tastes amazing so here's what you've
all been waiting for we're gonna
scramble some ostrich eggs okay and to
secure it I'm gonna put it in a bowl in
a bowl I'm gonna smack it to open it
chip away the pieces and just kind of
shake the egg up because I don't know
how else it's supposed to get out of
here
[Music]
so I know this probably doesn't look the
most appetizing but maybe it tastes good
in the season with us it's an assault a
ton of black pepper because it's
equivalent to 24 chicken eggs and I'm
gonna whisk it all together and just
whisk and whisk and whisk and whisk
because it took me forever to get this
all whisk now we're gonna cook it in
some butter like the others and I'm only
in a pour a bit of this in because
nobody needs that much scrambled ah
search eggs and it seems to cook up
pretty similar to the other ones it's a
bit looser maybe more watery this kind
of takes longer to cook to so we're
gonna put this straight on some toast
season with more salt and pepper and
here we have it scrambled ostrich eggs
this is like the eggs you get at a hotel
buffet
they may have come from a box they may
have come from an egg
who knows this definitely has a distinct
look it's super yellow like it's very
pigmented in color
let's try Oh No whoo I like this one I
just kind of feel like if you took egg
flavor and like turned it up a notch I
has a lot of flavor I'm not gonna lie is
the flavors good but the texture just
doesn't allow me to get past that it's
like super soft it just feels like a
more like full-bodied egg experience so
what Jake's crammed was the best let's
find out after tasting those four
different eggs I will have to say my
favorite is the fourth it was the most
different but most of all the flavor was
strongest I knew it I know I do I do it
after iving into the egg world I'm gonna
have to say that number one is the
winner because it just had the right
texture the right flavor that was really
good
wael eggs maybe I'll start ordering
quail eggs at my local diner so I look
for eggs that I tried I would say
that my winner is number one the flutter
eggs because they taste like butter and
I love butter and I love eggs and it's
like a perfect army together quail eggs
well if you like butter quails are where
it's at so there you have it
quail eggs make the best scrambled eggs
[Music]
hey unsolved is on a new channel
commander Kurn so describe here
[Music]